c'est d'abord notre aumônerie qui nous a
vraiment conseillé vivement d'y aller et
il s'est avéré que c'était vraiment un
très bon choix parce que je n'ai jamais
regretté une seule fois dit être allé
c'était une expérience a vraiment
exceptionnel c'était principalement pour
vivre une aventure avec mes amis
approfondir la fois et puis vivre des
lieux nouveaux parce que c'est sympa
l'aumônerie des toujours dans la salle
paroissiale mais c'est bien aussi de se
déplacer au départ je n'avais pas envie
d'y aller
et comme personne se décider au sein de
l'aumônerie pour les accompagner je me
suis dit allez je me lance et j'ai fait
j'en avais entendu parler et puis pas
parce que j'avais vu des reportages tout
temps en temps sur lourdes et je trouve
ça magnifique et puis parce que si ça
faisait partie donc du programme
d'aumônerie j'étais sceptique pour y
aller mais au final j'y suis allé parce
cheikh c'était quelque chose à faire
était au mans comme important de le
faire je suis pas j'ai pas regretter
j'ai accompagné les jeunes en tant
qu'animatrice d'aumônerie pendant deux
années j'ai eu envie d'avoir un temps
plus pour moi ce qui a été assez
contagieux c'est que dans la famille
mon mari a eu envie de venir aussi mes
enfants également
l'ambiance des piscines déjà ces
mystérieux quand on parle des piscines
on sait pas ce qui va se passer à
l'intérieur c'est ce qui m'a permis de
comprendre pourquoi les gens allaient
lourde parce que quand je suis arrivée à
lourdes je voyais tous ces gens et je me
demandais ce que je faisais là au milieu
d'eux parce que je ressentais pas grand
chose et je me suis jamais donné et j'ai
vécu un lourde différemment moi cela la
basilique du rosaire qui m'a beaucoup
marqué puisque base c'est une cathédrale
ça c'est une basilique magnifique et
puis on a participé à une messe et puis
c'est le partir et donc qu'il animait et
donc c'est vraiment génial quand on
arrive et qu'on voit pour la première
fois la statue de la vierge et quand on
voit tous les pèlerins autour de cette
statue qui sont en train de réciter des
je vous salue marie les prières à
longueur de journée j'ai beaucoup aimé
aussi le chemin de croix qui est
proposée juste au dessus de lourdes
c'était vraiment un moment très fort
avec tous ces pèlerins du monde entier
c'est la prière devant la grotte à
lourdes et la diversité des personnes
qui étaient là des malades bien portants
on entendait aussi des gens par les
différentes langues et 7,7 attention que
chacun pour le train quand on est dans
la basilique et qu'on voit tous les
prêtres diacres tout ça on les évêques
arriver ouais c'est ça c'est or on est
impressionnés quand même on me regardait
des malades et il y avait un mal être
qui voulait absolument qu'on fait ce
boom room
donc on l'a on courait dans lourdes
avaient faim avec son son fauteuil
roulant et irié rit aux éclats et
c'était vraiment beau la rencontre avec
les malades
est ce que j'ai aimé aussi c'est de voir
la transformation chez les jeunes
je pense que groupe est importante parce
qu'on on se portent les uns les autres
et on va plus à la rencontre de l'autre
partira avec donc l'aumônerie s'était
passé une expérience c'est très
sympathique parce que j'étais encore
jamais parti en voyage donc avec à un
groupe que ce soit des amis ou un groupe
d'aumônerie et puis c'était c'est
vraiment sympa ouest est une expérience
vraiment génial ça a permis de renforcer
considérablement les liens avec les
autres personnes de mon aumôneries de me
rendre compte qu'il y avait vraiment des
personnes exceptionnelles que je
connaissais pas forcément de très bien
avant
le fait de m'ouvrir plus facilement une
me laisser guider de mela de lâcher
prise et de faire confiance quand on a
fait le brancardage à lourdes
j'ai vu qu'il y avait vraiment des
personnes pour qui ça comptait
énormément et puis je me rendais pas
compte à ce moment là et puis ça m'a ça
m'a permis aussi donc de grandir dans ma
foi et puis de me rendre compte et donc
de prendre enfin que ça prenne une part
plus importante dans ma vie
je lui dirai ben vas-y eux
regarde autour de toi et tu vis vis le
moment présent à fond et tu rentreras
différemment après lourdes c'est
vraiment quelque chose de génial mais
dans tous les sens du terme
on s'amuse on prie on découvre des
choses sur nous mêmes et ça n'a pas de
prix
donc il faut vraiment qu'ils viennent